alert you are attempting to view the
file on scp-001
this file is highly classified and its
contents are sealed by the order of the
o5 council by continuing to view them
you are confirming that you have
received prior authorization if you're
found to be viewing these materials
without adequate clearance you will be
terminated if you choose to accept these
risks and verify your credentials access
will be granted in five four
three two
one the following is a truncated summary
based on transcripts from an official
meeting of the o5 council you have been
warned 05-1 sat at a conference table
addressing his colleagues all the other
council members looked at him
expectantly except one hello everyone
05-1 began i'm sure you're all wondering
why 13 is in here today i'll get to that
but i first want to publicly address
something i'm sure you've all noticed by
now after talking to you for the past
week or so i've noticed that we've all
been inducted onto the council almost at
the exact same time all of us except 13
that is in fact 13 probably conducted
your orientation the other council
members nodded that's good to know that
it wasn't just me 05-2 commented i would
have expected the last two to run me
through things 05-1 side indeed in fact
i asked 13 about it but he refused to
say much of course he pled ignorance but
i don't believe that as you might guess
the previous 1205s did not retire at the
same time they were killed in fact this
building isn't even the original site
zero one that was destroyed i think you
can see where this is going 05-3 frowned
so we have a dead o5 council a missing
site zero one and somehow none of this
is on our records and only one suspect
piped up 05-2 05-1 held up a hand
drawing attention back to his words i
would like to designate 05-13 as one of
our scp-001 projects of course this will
be kept secret from him but we need to
investigate this entire ordeal until we
figure out what happened how it happened
and why o5-13 is the only one left
standing after the aforementioned
conference o5-13 was designated as
cp-001
scp-001 is a male human of latin
american descent standing at
approximately 1.9 meters tall the exact
nature of this entity and the anomalous
properties he possesses are not yet
known he was given his anomalous
classification following the caesar
incident an event that resulted in the
death of all previous 05 council members
aside from 13 the complete eradication
of the previous site-01 and the loss of
any official documentation on 13 or his
appointment to the council scp-001 is
contained in a modified containment
facility constructed similarly to other
foundation sites with the exception of
additional living arrangements for the
members of the overwatch council the
facility is equipped with
state-of-the-art security cameras as
well as three nuclear warheads intended
as fail safes these will detonate if
scp-001 breaches containment one
designated member of the council is to
be given amnestic drugs on a regular
basis and maintain official
documentation of all information
gathered about
scp-001 this council member will be
referred to as the archivist and will
hold the position for approximately four
months at a time though they may
terminate their duties sooner if the
domestic side effects prove too
detrimental to their health when a
council member's time as the archivist
comes to a close they must conduct a
meeting to assess what they have learned
05-1 was appointed to the role of
inaugural archivist and several months
later
a second conference was called one of
the subjects discussed was a series of
interviews conducted with survivors of
the caesar incident though several
members of personnel made it out
relatively unscathed they had no memory
of the incident at all and their
interviews were unfortunately of no help
during the events of the conference
05-10 revealed that he had recovered a
copy of the previous 05 personnel
dossier it included an entry that
described 05-13's purpose on the council
stating
05-13 special connection to the
anomalous gives him a perspective no
other council member could begin to
fathom while normalcy confirmation
meetings require 11 members for quorum
no meeting is allowed to proceed without
05-13's attendance in addition to this
entry there was a table recording
05-13's various anomalous property
measurements perplexingly his appearance
temperature skeletal structure corporal
reality and induced emotional states
were all found to be within the baseline
of normality the remainder of the
conference was designated to deciding
the next steps for a series of
specialized teams looking into the
caesar incident
scp-001's origin and the entity's
anomalous properties o5-8 was selected
as the next archivist and the meeting
disbanded with a new sense of purpose
the caesar incident team managed to
identify the geographical location of
the previous site-01 by searching for
records of unusual seismic activity on
the date of the incident earthquake
records led them to an island off the
coast of greenland where the remains of
the site were waiting an investigative
team attempted to search the island but
was prevented from exploring the ruins
by representatives of the global occult
coalition who demanded they leave
immediately investigation into the
presence of the goc on the island turned
up a curious connection their
representatives had spoken with 05-13
before setting up an outpost there
meanwhile the origins investigation team
looked into records of 05-13 at various
groups of interest reports were
conflicting and difficult to parse and
the team brought their findings to the
third conference notice from 05-8
conference number three was cut short
after an intense exchange led to enough
people leaving the meeting for us to
lose quorum we archived all the
materials covered up into that point as
well as the efforts made to de-escalate
tension between the members however this
also means that information herein was
not properly vetted by the entire
council before being uploaded so we add
on the conservative side if you need to
see the full proceedings please contact
the current archivist before the
premature adjourning of the conference
the following conversation took place
05-1 excuse me for i believe some
clarification regarding the exchange
with marshall carter and doc is
necessary how so it mentions here that
you performed in exchange it is
important for the records and for our
general information security that we
know exactly what information was
exchanged yes that does make sense i'm
sorry i did not write that section of
the report if my memory serves me well
seven was responsible for the marshall
carter and dark reconnaissance well
seven could you elaborate 05-7 looked at
05-1 and swallowed you know the rules
are pretty tight on this why did you
give them anything in the first place
yeah 11 makes a good point don't we have
our own spies working some of the
transport routes 05-7 nodded and then
began going through her belongings could
you at least tell us what kind of
information you gave zem 05-7 paused
thought to herself for a moment and then
motioned to the entire council wait you
gave them information about us 05-7
shook her head paused again and then
nodded her head yes she held up a finger
and then went back to looking through
her files but that's no i i don't
believe this we can't let people know
about us no matter the situation imagine
if word got out that the old council had
been killed i bet colts across the
planet would have a heyday i doubt she
said anything actually important oh
really i've only dealt with the
merchants once or twice but they know
how to appraise anything especially
information 05-7 held up an index finger
and then continued looking through her
files
are you just going to ignore the issue
then just gonna hang us out to dry
eleven you need to calm down we're all
waiting on you 05-7 looked up at 05-11
and then put her files away she gathered
her things and left the room
camp dake being called out i see eleven
i will need to speak with you following
this meeting you can talk to me now i'll
be in my office oh 5-11 left the room
eighth i'd like to go after seven to
make sure she didn't actually do
something stupid that's fine i believe
that would drop us below quorum but i
believe this meeting has fallen apart
anyway juan 12 and i will make the next
update ourselves this scp-001 conference
is dismissed addendum an update has been
added to this file by 05-8 regarding
security concerns following the official
ending of the meeting 05-7 distributed
the summary of all information exchanged
with marshall carter and dark the
information was pulled from the out of
date 05 dossier the current explanation
as to why it was accepted by the group
of interest is that it would have
confirmed any information they had
gathered previously about the o5 council
as part of the exchange we have received
a tip as to where to find more
information on
scp-001 which the origins team will
investigate for the next conference 05-7
later clarified in a written statement
that she had left the meeting simply to
retrieve the file detailing this
information since it was not on her
person 05-7 insisted that she does not
need an interpreter due to information
security concerns a discussion was
scheduled between her and 05-1 to reduce
communicational issues at a later date
05-11 issued a formal apology i hope
that this will be a cessation of any
internal conflicts we are working
together and therefore require that a
trusting relationship has been
established between all members as
abraham lincoln once said a house
divided against itself cannot stand
o5-12 was appointed to the position of
archivist and after several months
passed a fourth conference was called
the following is an excerpt from this
meeting two why doesn't your theme start
this off all right sure we did make some
nice progress always good to start a
meeting on a high note you all remember
those four survivors we talked about
last meeting right we got back in touch
with them and did a more
thorough interview more intense
techniques lie detector tests heart rate
monitoring the whole shebang do you have
transcripts i do but spoiler alert
they're not very different from the
first round so we're now convinced they
genuinely don't remember how far does
13's anti-mimetic side reach slow down
there we're not quite done you see as
part of our second round of interviews
we also did a physical examination and
some tests to see what messed with their
heads and we found they all had a little
scar right on the side of their necks
right where we inject amnestics i mean
while i understand what you're implying
we tend to administer amnestics fairly
liberally last meeting was essentially
just a prolonged reminder of how much we
value infosec true but we keep good
records of who we use with that stuff
how much we're using if we're using the
pills or the syringe etc etc however
when i went to look up if any of our
survivors had ever taken the injectable
amnestic all my results came back
negative i also took the liberty of
checking out red right hand the entire
squad's got injection scars and we
rarely wipe those guys whatever happened
i think we covered it up ourselves when
you say ourselves do you mean oh no no
no no
i just mean the foundation if we were
actually involved then everyone here
would have those scars but six nine and
i definitely don't have them so that
leads me to believe they didn't drug us
it would be an all or nothing deal good
work sounds like eight needs to have a
talk with our amnestics department
wait wait wait sorry i'm still trying to
keep all the details in order you said
that they were injected yes see that's
what i don't get we used the injections
like 10 years ago we moved onto the pill
since you can miss a vein also i checked
our amnestic supply right after the
caesar event and we didn't see any
variation from our normal usage
maybe the records are off we found that
whatever 13 did he's good at covering up
his tracks i don't think that's it
because you know who does still use
those injectable amnestics the goc
i see we'll have to schedule another
meeting with our good friends at the un
as well after discussing potential
origins for scp-001
the council moved on to the subject of
05-13's anomalous properties the
anomalous properties team presented
their findings okay so everyone here has
the records of our measurements also i
can tell you now they are not
particularly insightful uh do you have
too many leads to choose from ah well
quite the opposite actually we have
nothing nothing abnormal with regard to
radiation humes radio frequencies 13 is
almost impressively normal are you sure
we're not going about this wrong i mean
i know we've kind of quantified some of
our anomalies in the past but as a
general rule they're not supposed to
follow the rules right that is what i
was beginning to suspect also it is
troubling that he can just hide it from
us entirely or there is the other option
we're not only backing up the wrong tree
but we're in the entirely wrong forest
you're saying he's not even anomalous in
the first place it's hyzes at or verde
link visage under god who knows the
foundation better than even vedo let's
continue to discuss the non-anomalous
option since it appears that there would
be very little we could do about the
other case
so that would mean he's probably an
inside man for the insurgency or the
serpent's hand nein nein not a hand they
don't operate like this he might be a
fittest fanatic not that too or maybe
he's with someone else we've seen quite
a bit of the goc and uiu popping up in
this my apologies but i do find it
difficult to believe that a single
insurgent would be able to detonate the
on-site nuclear warhead from halfway
across the globe if we believe our
previous information i'm not so chevy
kanso it sounds like he spoke to our
regular body double maybe his anomalous
properties that he can create body
doubles but what are we supposed to do
with that excuse me i'd like to return
to the earlier line of discussion about
13 being unable to perform the
assassination due to possibly meeting
with our point of contact because i'm
beginning to believe that he actually
did meet with 13. so you believe he was
able to blow site-01 sky high from
halfway across the globe i mean for
going with a god theory i could see it
no i'm saying he had hell or at least
more than one man helping it remember
how our request to install additional
security cameras was denied by the
ethics committee you finally talked to
them i did i met with mr huang to demand
an explanation he refused and told me it
was above my security clearance
above your security clearance you're on
the god damn council there simply aren't
things outside of your jurisdiction you
run the ethics committee for god's sakes
ah that's not quite accurate i'm not in
charge of the ethics committee i'm
simply the o5 ambassador to it they need
to be a separate entity to eliminate
bias in various cases so you believe
that 13 is in league with the ethics
committee aussie administrator if it's
set above your security clearance or
both whoever it is they're trying very
hard to stop us from seeing him in
private someone should just let us give
him a full physical he's probably
baseline this would let us confirm that
yeah but if we're wrong and our god
theory is correct he'll blow our asses
sky high like the last council i believe
we need to adjourn here so we have
enough time to prepare for our next full
council meeting to avoid suspicion
although we do not need to expand our
search further i will consider speaking
to 13 before the next conference but i
will only do so if i believe it will not
result in a second caesar incident are
there any objections to this the council
fell silent then i believe this
conference is dismissed alert retina
scan confirmed identity verified your
credentials have been accepted and
further access has been granted welcome
05-13 you have one new message hello13
i'm sure you've been keeping dabs on
your fellow council's progress they're
growing closer than either of us wanted
but i'm not surprised when you get
enough smart people together they tend
to surpass your expectations you're
probably hoping this is going to end
soon i'm sorry you've gone through this
it obviously wasn't in our plan for you
when we inducted you into the council
but if you could keep up our gambit a
little longer i would be appreciative
i'm unconvinced your cohorts are ready
to know what happened to the
predecessors and i don't want to ask al
fine and johnson to help clean up
another may 13th i don't even want the
thought of pulling a caesar event in
their heads the goc and the uiu already
have enough dangling over my head as is
but if they do approach you and confront
you about the situation i'd rather you
have a direct answer also transcripts
tend to be more convincing than recall
i've attached here the transcript from
the o5 meeting before the caesar
incident it's part of the last minute
backup that site-01 performed as part of
stage 3 containment breach protocols if
anyone asks where those backups are
stored you can tell them the same thing
i told you it's beyond their clearance
love the administrator 05-1 was present
in the 05 council conference room he was
working at a laptop in front of him
beside which sat a cup of coffee a
message flashed up on his screen reading
access granted you have five minutes to
complete an action before the session
automatically shuts down he grumbled to
himself irritated two minutes pass
before the remaining council members
except for o5-13 enter the room you're
all here great i wouldn't want one of
you to be off-site for this juan what's
this about i know you've been going
through a phase lately but emergency
meetings demand a real emergency oh it's
an emergency alright then spit it out we
have a breach new xk level threat no
it's more of something under two's
jurisdiction we have an internal affairs
issue 05-1 motion to the coffee one of
you bastards thought i would actually
drink this
someone didn't give you enough sugar no
too much arsenic another message flashed
up on the computer reading you have
three minutes to complete an action
before the session automatically shuts
down do you want to finish with that
that pain in the ass can be patient wait
wait wait wait you think one of us tried
to kill you with your coffee oh don't
act like that's below you i know you've
all been out to bury my ass one calm
down i know we've had our differences
but but what it's not like this is the
first time one of you has tried to
destroy me i know you all once tried to
infiltrate one of my transports
infiltrated he was assigned to fill in
for it's no use five the man can't think
straight anymore oh really who's the one
here with his head so far up marshall's
ass he can taste the curvier you're
accusing me of selling out
no no i'm accusing all of you of selling
out or being out for yourself or some
nonsense you've all gone soft it used to
be if it doesn't make sense throw it in
the cage now it's let's measure it look
at it figure out what it is then make
sure it doesn't bother anyone that's not
containment that's sitting idly and
hoping the public doesn't find it my god
we've started outsourcing to pet
shelters you know if this is a problem
we can just calm down and rethink our
stances on a few things
that won't change anything half of you
are under someone's thumb and the other
half of you are so messed up you need a
cell of your own says the man who
suggested we drink from the fountain of
youth well seven you're right i'm about
as far from baseline as the rest of you
my god dammit anomalies are essentially
running this organization the computer
chimed in saying you have two minutes to
complete an action before the session
automatically shuts down shut up god
damn it we're getting off topic you said
someone poisoned you what about 13 he's
not even here that's because i sent him
to talk to nobody but why because he's
the only one i trust he's the only one i
don't need to have this chat with he's
the only normal person on this whole
goddamn council we plucked him off the
streets and just started asking him do
you think this is weird i'm not worried
about someone whose movements we've been
able to monitor since he came out of the
uterus you freaks i don't know what you
all did before you showed up here for
all i know you're just eldritch
abominations waiting for the chance to
kill me dead one
slow down they were so wrapped up in
their argument they barely noticed the
computer saying you have one minute to
complete an action before the session
automatically shuts down
and you know what we've always been
pretty liberal with containing anomalies
now we might have 12 of them on the
council one what your session just
finish it already it's distracting as
all hell you know you're right i should
just finish it already there's not much
more for me to do 05-1 resumed his work
at the computer aside from containing
you like the inhuman aberrations you are
but it was a little too late for that
the computer which had been allowed to
time out said emergency stage 3
containment breach protocol activated
the on-site nuclear warhead will
detonate in five four
three two
one this concludes the file on scp-001
it appears that in a place dedicated to
studying the strange and unusual where
the bizarre and anomalous have become
the pedestrian the usual just another
day at the office the most notable thing
a person can be is completely average
when the impossible becomes possible
when you and everyone around you are the
furthest thing from normal the ordinary
is the stuff of nightmares now go check
out
scp-001 does not exist and scp-001
a simple toy maker for more proposals
pertaining to the endless mysteries of
scp-001